it's great to be joined today by
Samantha price who's an evolutionary
biologist and also assistant professor
at Clemson University
Samantha it's so great to talk to you
you know I've been reading so much over
the last years not only about some of
these very large extinct mammals which
are no longer around and a lot of the
context of that reading has
unfortunately been reading that that
points to humans having a role in in
some of those extinctions but also about
the size of whales and I think maybe
just as a sort of general introduction
to the topic it might be interesting for
our audience to hear a little bit about
what sort of factors in general control
or influence the size that a particular
mammal species grows to write well there
are a lot of things and a lot of it
comes down to the laws of physics and so
on land a lot of that is to do with the
effect of gravity on bone and so the
material properties of bone really sort
of constrain how big they can get on
land because you just can't move
something so big so some of the the
largest things that ever lived on land
they would dinosaur so not mammals they
got up to around maybe a hundred and
sixty thousand pounds obviously that's
an estimate because we can't weigh a
dinosaur but we think that sort of close
to the maximum size that things can get
on land due to those sort of laws of
physics and the capacity of bone to be
able to sort of hold our bodies up of
course when you get into the sea and you
mentioned whales they don't have those
effect gravitational constraints because
of the buoyancy of water and so that's
one of the reasons that we think that
things can evolve to be much larger in
water is to do to that buoyancy there
are also many other factors as well but
that's one of the key things that sort
of put our upper limits at least on land
can you talk a little bit about the
connection between an animal's diet and
food consumption and its ultimate size
and I know that there is something
called climbers law which sort of is a
ratio between how much food and animal
consumes
and how much bigger how much bigger in
terms of body weight it gets and I'm
wondering whether that I genuinely don't
know does that apply differently if you
are a mammal in water versus a land
mammal right so close look it's an
interesting question we're not quite
sure if it climbers law really is
dictating the upper size it may actually
so that's all to do with sort of volume
of an animal and so the bigger you get
you're not using as much energy per unit
volume and so the idea is that you can
eat less nutritious prey ie plants so
doll so much prey but you can graze you
can get your nutrition from these very
abundant plants and you can extract the
energy because you don't need quite as
much energy per unit of mass when you're
larger because our metabolic rate
roughly scales with a 3/4 rule to our
sign so it doesn't increase as much as
as our science does however it may just
be that plants are just more numerous in
the terrestrial environment and
therefore we're just the big things are
just eating the most available things so
it may not be particularly driven by
climbers rule and the way that's very
different in the oceans is there is not
an equivalent of krill so these very
small highly nutritious animal protein
packets that aggregate in these very
large sort of groups during upwelling
and that's what these very large whales
are eating and so it may just be the
difference in availability of protein so
plants aren't so nutritious but they're
very abundant on land
where's krill they're very abundant in
the oceans and they're much more
nutritious that's interesting so if we
accounted for if we held level the sort
of gravity related constraints that
allow whales in water to grow as big as
they do but did a thought experiment a
assuming a different diet for whales
would that conceivably allow for even
larger whales or is this sort of the
optimal way that we would get the
largest whales given that the large ones
eat a lot of krill as you mentioned
right I mean I mean I don't think we
quite know that obviously the largest
living vertebra is the blue whale and
it's the largest vertebrate ever to have
lived and it eats krill we do have a
thought experiment in terms of we have
marine herbivores so the manatees and
dugongs and they don't get anywhere near
the sights of the blue whale so we
suspect that one of the major driving
forces are these sort of aggregations of
krill that have led to those absolutely
gianormous sizes and agree well as a
general principle do species that live
longer tend to have at least the
opportunity of growing larger just in
the sense that it takes time to grow and
the more years you have to do it the
larger you could possibly grow or does
that not seem to be a correlation it's a
very strong correlation so there is a
very strong correlation between sort of
average age and maximum age and body
size so the largest things are the
longest lived because it takes you a
long time to get to that size it takes
you a long time to grow to a size where
you can reproduce and so you have a very
long sort of juvenile stage as well
before you can even start to reproduce
then you can't have multiple offspring
so you're only having one offspring each
time you're having a reproductive event
and so it tends to lead to sort of a lot
longer life yes I know that climate
science is not your area of expertise
but I'm curious if you have any thoughts
at least with regard to whale size and
and
other ocean animals do we know how for
example changes in ocean temperature
ocean acidification which we've talked
with with experts in that field about
and things like the Pacific Garbage
Patch how does that impact
what's going on in terms of animal size
in the ocean so there are there's a
variety of things there that you asked
me in terms of the Garbage Patch it's
certainly having an impact on whales and
other marine organisms in terms if they
are eating these often the plastic bags
are looking like squid and so things
that feed on squid will or jellyfish
will try and eat them and so things have
Worcester up control with large amounts
of garbage in their stomachs and so that
is certainly worrying in terms of what
it has the size I'm not so sure but the
climate change potentially could be
really important so there's been a study
that showed that these very large whales
the blue whales they've sort of only
evolved over the last sort of four and a
half million years ago and they think
that that is really closely linked to
the onset of these seasonal upwelling
events in the ocean and quite a lot of
oceanic changes that led to those
greater aggregations of krill and so of
course climate change anything that
affects the ocean currents and the
upwelling is likely to have an effect on
these very largest whales and I don't we
don't know what they will be but
everybody is of course concerned about
that is it likely to expect that the
super large mammals of the past would
would re-emerge somehow at some point
like what forces could cause that you
know whether we're talking about like
the the large armed and armored mammals
of the past or glyptodont or the ground
sloth I mean what what might make these
resurface or are these basically things
of the past um well I mean the obviously
the the physical constraints are going
to say the same so that is true so it's
then all about sort of the availability
basically of food and what they will be
living on as well as the Predators that
would be after them also diseases that
may be affecting them there really is no
reason to expect that we wouldn't see
the evolution of large things again as
you
mentioned in the introduction a lot of
the sort of land mammals that recently
went extinct have been linked to human
evolution and as sort of driving the
helping to drive the extinction of
things like the mammoth and the mastodon
and things like that so there's no real
theoretical reason why those shouldn't
really humans are are preventing that by
changing the habitat we don't have these
vast savannas that things can survive in
no in Africa we still have some of those
places that's where the elephants on the
drop on our largest land mammals are for
species particularly mammals that have
been around for for a long time and have
not gone extinct do we know whether the
average member of a particular species
is larger or smaller now so for example
if we compared blue whales now to blue
whales of millions of years ago or the
African elephant today compared to an
older elephant in general what direction
is size going ah well there are a lot of
theories on that I mean with the whales
we don't have we have a fantastic fossil
record through the history of whales but
for the modern species we down really
don't have a great fossil record that we
can identify or we know this is the blue
whale a million years ago so that's a
little hard what we can do is we can see
that different environments lead to the
selection for different signs so on
islands what we see were elephants and
we can see this in the fossil record of
elephants is that they get smaller when
they move onto islands so Islands are a
lot smaller so there's just sort of not
that sort of availability of habitat and
food and so they tend to evolve much
smaller sizes and but small things small
mammals when they get onto islands often
get quite big and that may be a release
of constraint from other predators or
various other aspects to that absolutely
that is so basically there's no answer
in general for mammals it depends on
what animals were talking about right
and there is a very long-standing
hypothesis
since the sort of late 1800s called by a
pretty famous paleontologists called
coke and he his hypothesis is that
mammals have been getting bigger through
time but the evidence for that is
somewhat controversial and so some
people think there is really strong
evidence and others are less sure so I
certainly wouldn't like to say that they
have been getting bigger throughout time
but there's certainly some trends in
certain groups though they are getting
bigger spoken with with true in a truly
diplomatic way I would say I think I
understand
Samantha price is an evolutionary
biologist and also an assistant
professor at Clemson University
thanks so much for talking to us about
some of the work that you do thank you
very much it was a pleasure